♪♪
There's a primal urge
in all of us...
To explore.
Some say private citizens
have no business
in space exploration.
I emphatically disagree.
We have a historic
opportunity...
The first mission to Mars.
NASA's joining Helios
and the Soviets.
A three way race to Mars.
We're not going to come
in second place again.
To anyone.
We're talking about discovering
life on another planet.
It'll change our
concept of who we are.
Where we're going.
♪ Black hole sun ♪
♪ Won't you come ♪
The massive dust storm has obscured
both landing sites.
Years even decades of
planning comes down...
To this moment.
We're landing blind.
Brace for impact.
Being first is what
it's all about.
♪ Won't you come ♪
This is the resource that can
support large scale
human colonization.
Wanna tell us where
the water is?
The survival of my
crew depends on it.
♪ Won't you come ♪
♪ Black hole sun ♪
When united behind
a common goal
there is nothing...
We cannot achieve.
It's only the beginning.
♪ Won't you come ♪